[موسيقى]
انها ثامنه بتوقيت جرينتش الحادي عشر
بتوقيت الرياض انا صهيب شرايير وهذه اخبار
الساعه
يوم غير عادي في امريكا شلل يضرب حركه
الطيران بسبب خلل فني والسيناريو يتكرر
بكندا لكن بلا تعطيه
حكومه طالبان تقول للعربيه ان داعش ظاهره
تكفيريه غير مرئيه واقصاء المراه من
التعليم شان الاماره
[موسيقى]
وفي مصر الجنيه في ادنا مستوى له امام
الدولار بعد الانتقال لنظام صرف اكثر
مرونه
بطريقه مبتكره مكتبه بريطانيه تروج لكتاب
الامير هاري عبر وضعه بجانب روايه كيف
تقتل عائلتك
[موسيقى]
انه يوم غير عادي في الولايات المتحده في
مشهد نادر خلت الاجواء الامريكيه كليا من
الطائرات لعده ساعات فالحركه الجويه شهدت
تعطل تاما في كامل الولايات المتحده هو
الاكبر منذ احداث الحادي عشر من سبتمبر
حين تعرضت البلاد الي هجمات ارهابيه ضخمه
كيف بدات المشكله بدايه اعلنت اداره
الطيران الفيدراليه عن تعطل نظام نوتم
المسؤول عن ارشادي وتوجيه التيارين على
مستوى الاجواء الامريكيه وحتى بنسبه
للطائرات القادمه اليها وبمجرد اكتشاف
الخلل امرت هيئه الطيران الفيدرالي بوقف
اقلاع الطائرات من جميع مطارات البلاد
سواء للرحله الداخليه او الخارجيه بعدها
مباشره وجهت الاداره الفيدراليه للطيران
تعليمات الى جميع الطائرات المحلقه فوق
اجواء البلاد بالهبوط فورا وفي مرحله
الثالثه قامت الجهه المعنيه باصدار
توجيهات لجميع الطائرات القادمه لاجواءها
بضروره تغيير المسار او عدم الاقلاع من
الاساس
وهذه الصوره مشاهدينا تظهر اجواء الولايات
المتحده بعد هذه الاجراءات
وفيما بعد اعلى لك اداره طيران الفيدراليه
الامريكيه عوده حركه الطيران الى طبيعتها
بشكل تدريجي وتحدثت وسائل الاعلام
الامريكيه عن تاجيل اكثر من 4000 رحله
والغاء نحوي 750 رحله اخرى بسببها هذا
التوقف
عوده حركه الطيران الى طبيعتها بشكل
تدريجي بعد توقفها بسبب بهذا العطل
التقنيه الذي اصاب نظام اشعارات حركه
الطيران وتحدثت وسائل الاعلام الامريكيه
عن تاجيل اكثر من 4000 رحله اذا كما ذكرنا
والغاء نحو 750 رحله من مطار دالاس في
فرجينيا
اذا عوده حركه الملاحه الى طبيعتها في
المطارات الامريكيه هنا في مطار الدلس في
ولايه فرجينيا نرى الطائرات تهبط وتقلع
بسلام دون اي مشاكل طبعا هيئه الملاحه
قالت بنها سترفع الحظر وبالفعل رفعته نرى
بعض المسافرين هنا الذين ينتظرون حقائبهم
لكن الرحلات الخارجيه لم تتاثر تحدث مع
اكثر من مسافر اتو من الخارج قالوا بانهم
حتى لم يعرفوا بالموضوع او بهذا الخلل لكن
التدعيات السياسيه ستكون كبيره وخصوصا في
مجلس النواب الذي سيطلب موسى من وزير
المواصلات طبعا الحديث الان هو عن عطل فني
في داخل الحاسوب الاساسي الذي يزود
الملاحين او الصيادين بالمعلومات الاساسيه
لذا كجراء احترازي تم همم حظر جميع
السيارات الطائرات في المطارات الامريكيه
من الاقناع همم لكن همم استبعاد له سبراني
الرئيس بعد ان قال بانه لا يعرف السبب لكن
هناك تحقيق شامل ومساءله وخصوصا لاداره
الرئيس بايدن حتى لو لم يكن الخطر امني لا
الامر غير مقبول بالنسبه للجمهوريين
وبالنسبه للامريكيين لماذا يحدث هذا الخطا
الذي يتسبب به ملايين من الدولارات في
الخسائر لكن العوده حتى الان الطبيعيه على
الاقل في مطار دالاس في اولاد برج الجدي
الى استعاده النظام الامان المتاثر
بالانقطاع الليلي بشكل كامل كما وجه وزير
النقل بتسريع الاجراءات لتحديد الاسباب
الجذريه والتوصيه بالخطوات التاليه
انا الان موجوده في مطار رونالدو المحادي
للعاصمه الامريكيه واشنطن عندما اتينا في
ساعات الصباح الاولى كان هناك عدد من
الطائرات متوقف على المدرج ولكن مع الساعه
9:00 صباحا بدات هذه الطائرات بالاقلاع
ولكن ما زلنا نشاهد ان هناك تاخير بسبب
اعاده جدوله الرحلات كمان نشاهد هنا على
الشاشه هناك رحلات تم الغائها واخرى تم
تاجيلها وهناك رحلات ما زالت على موعدها
نسيمها الرحلات التي تقوم بعد الظهر
بالنسبه للمسافرين عبروا عن انزعاجهم
بطبيعه الحال ولكن كما نرى انهم ما زالوا
يحاولون الحصول على تذاكر او تعديل
رحلاتهم الجويه الى الوجهات التي سيذهبون
اليها
نتابع ايضا من مطري دلاس في فرجينيا ومطار
رونالدو مع مراسلتي العربيه ناديه
البلبيسي اهلا بك وريتا سليمان اهلا بك
ايضا بدايه معك ناديه هل عادت حركه
الطيران طبيعه تماما عندك
نعم مئه بالمئه بالنسبه للاق
لاع لها قبل قليل صهيب وتقدر بالالاف التي
تاخرت لساعتين او تم الغائها تماما ستضطر
هذه الشركات التعامل مع المسافرين يعني
هناك مسافرين كانوا ينتظرون لسعاد طويله
لا يعرفون اذا كانوا سيقعون اذا كان هناك
ترانزيت ما بين طائره وطائره ينتقلون الى
مكان اخر لكن بشكل عام منذ ساعات صباح
الاولى حتى الان نستطيع ان نقول بانه في
مطار دالاس في ولايه فرجينيا وهو اكبر
المطارات الذي يخدم العاصمه واشنطن وتاتي
فيه رحلات من الخارج ليس فقط رحله داخليه
ااه تحدث مع اكثر من مسافر علامات طائرات
اتت من الخارج اثيوبيا وقطر وغيرها همم
طبعا حركه الملاحه عادت الى طبيعتها لكن
هو التساؤل الذي سيطرح نفسه ما سبب الخلل
حتى الان لا نعرف هو سبب
سليمان كيف هي الحركه وحركه المسافرين
كذلك
الحركه هنا عدد طبيعيه بالنسبه لي الطيران
صهيب وايضا بالنسبه للمسافرين حركه تدفق
المسافرين ثالثه تماما الان ااا مع تاجيل
عدد كبير من الرحلات في هذا المطار
على مستوى البلاد تم تاجيل اكثر من ثمانيه
الاف رحله ااه حتى اللحظه والغاء اكثر من
19 رحله ايضا اود ان اشير بانه تاخير
الرحلات اتى بسبب اعاده جدوله هذه الرحلات
بسبب العطل والتوقف الذي استمر لعده ساعات
صباحا همم هذا ما ادى الى تاجيل الرحلات
الان حركات هبوط طيران والاقلاع عدد طبيعه
تماما وايضا المسافرين هنا همم
طبيعيه همم
يذهبون الى طائراتهم الى ويلحقون برحلاتهم
همم
ليس هناك توضيح حتى الان همم يفسر سبب هذا
العطل الذي اوقف حركه همم الطيران في
امريكا همم اليوم لكن كيف هو تعاطي
الاعلام وردود فعل الامريكيين يعني لا
نتحدث على دوله كبيره مثل الولايات
المتحده وقطاع مهم يربطها ليس فقط بالداخل
بالخارج ايضا كيف هي ردود الافعال حول هذا
العطل
نبدا باهم رد فعل وهو من الكونغرس من مجلس
النواب الذي يسيطر عليه الجمهوريون قال
طبعا كيف المراتي صباح اليوم بين الامر
مقلق وغير مقبول همم هناك من دعا الى
تحقيق شامل وكامل بما فيه وزير المواصلات
في بوتجاج لكن ايضا هناك جلسات موسى على
واستماع سيطلب فيها الجمهوريون ان ياتي
مسؤولين كبار في اداره رئيس الاجابه على
هذه الاسئله كما قلت هذه اكبر دوله صناعيه
في العالم كله يعني من غير المقبول ان
تتعطل حركه الملاحه في كل انحاء الولايات
المتحده طبعا استبعدنا الهجوم السيبراني
وهذا كان منذ الصباح عندما اعلن الرئيس
وايضا الوزير المواصلات همم قبل قليل في
المؤتمر الصحفي في البيت الابيض لكن بشكل
عام هناك من يتهم الاداره بانها تقوم
بتعيين اشخاص على حساب الكفاءه في المرافق
الحيويه مثل المطارات وطبعا على اساس ان
يكون هناك مساواه بين الامريكيين من اصول
الافريقيه والامريكيين وصول بيضاء وغيرها
وتوظيف ال- ال- الاقليات لكن هذه اتهامات
لا نستطيع طبعا لا يستطيع احد ان يثبتها
لكن على كل الاحوال هناك عاصفه سياسيه
وحتى صار ماديه بالدرجه الاولى
تمكنت من جمعها وما يتردد كذلك في الاعلام
الامريكي حول اسباب هذا العطل الفني
الكبير مع ما ذكرته ناديه طبعا استبعاد
فرضيه الهجوم استمراني كما قالت المتحدث
باسم البيت الابيض
الاسباب لا زالت غير واضحه حتى اللحظه لم
يتم الاعلان عنها ربما بانتظار الاعلان عن
النتيجه النهائيه من قبل وزاره النقل
الامريكيه تماما ولكن الحديث الذي قاله
وزير النقل في مقابله صحفيه ذكر بانه كان
هناك خلل اثناء الليل ادى الى انقطاع في
النظام الذي يسمح باستمرار تدفق المعلومات
بسلاسه في همم للطائرات التي تحتاجها
الطائرات طبعا وهذا ادى الى القلق من
سلامه همم الاقلاع هذه الطائرات تحديدا
ونظرا بانه الولايات المتحده تشدد على
اهميه سلامه الطيران ارتوا بالغاء الرحلات
او تعليقها لحتى اصلاح هذا الخطا طبعا
التحقيقات لا سالت مستمره لمعرفه سبب تعطل
هذا النظام تحديدا
لمحاولات همم من طول هذا الامر مشددا همم
وايضا ركز همم وزير النقل بمقابلته على
انه همم سيتم البحث باصلاح همم ووضع خطط
جديده لهيئه همم الطيران الفيدراليه التي
اعترف نوعا باب بانها تحتاج الى تجديد
العربيه ريتا سليمان وناديه البلبيسي من
مطار رونالدو ومن مطار دالاس في فرجينيا
شكرا جزيلا
قال الرئيس الامريكي لا يعرف اسباب العطل
مضيفا انه اصدر توجيهات لوزاره النقل
باجراء تحقيقه بشان تعطل حركه الطيران
تحدثت وزير النقل الامريكي لا يعرف السبب
حتى الان ولكنني تحدثت معه على الهاتف
لمده 10 دقائق واخبرتها ان يعلمني بكل
تطورات لا يزال بامكان الطائرات الوجود
بامان لكنهم لا يستطيعون الاقلاع اتوقع
انه في غضونه بضع ساعات سيكون لدينا فكره
جيده عن سبب التعطيل
وعن امكانيه ان يكون سبب العطله هجوما
الكترونيا ان كما ذكرت ناديه قبل قليل
اكدت الناطق باسم البيت الابيض كارين
جونكر في تغريده لها انه لا يوجد دليل على
هجوم الكترونيا في هذه المرحله
وسيناريو امريكا سرعان ما تكرر في كندا
حيث اعلنت هيئه المراقبه الجويه الكنديه
ان النظام للطيران واجه انقطاعا دون تاخير
على الرحلات
نعرف اكثر
احمد بنافع استاذ الهندسه وامن الشبكات في
جامعه سان خوسيه دكتور اهلا بك معنا ما هو
نظام
مساند لبرج المراقبه بمعنى انه بيدي فكره
للطيرين اذا كان في عمليه في اي مشاكل
حاصله في المطار من ناحيه الجو من ناحيه
تصليحات من ناحيه مثلا عرض جوي حاصل في
المنطقه اللي حوالينهم فاي اي واحد من
الكباتنه او الطيران قبل حتى ما يقلع همم
يتصل عليهم بيسالهم فهم يعني بيدوا له
عمليه التصريح انه همم انه يقلع بالطياره
نعم طيب هذا العطل الفني ما عسى يكون
السبب في تعطل يا دكتور احمد
شوفي يا اخ صهيب انا حاقول لك بصراحه انا
اشتغلت في بدايه العشق 2000 مع شركه
تتعامل مع مبنى الاتصالات اللي في اتلانت
تبعت لهيئه الملاحه مبنى كبير يعني 15 دور
فوق الارض وسبعه تحت الارض الاجهزه اللي
عندهم قديمه فهم في فتره طويله هم
بيحاولوا يجددوا الاجهزه الى فتره قريبه
كانت هذه الخدمه هذه اللي هو بيشوفها حاله
المطار كانت تم عن طريق التلفون الكابتن
بيتصل بالتليفون على المركز المراقبه
ويسالهم اذا كان في اي مشاكل في المطار
فهم تدريجين بيحاولوا يطوروا وخلافه
التطوير هذا ممكن تحصل مشاكل كثيره طيب
همم هذا يعيدنا يعني همم ربما عدني الى
فتره الانتخابات الرئاسيه الامريكيه عندما
كانت ترامب يتحدث على سوء المطارات
الامريكيه بالمقارنه مثلا مع مطرات دول
الخليج هل فعلا يعني هذا تاكد ان حاله
المطارات الامريكيه يعني وصلت الى هذه
المرحله من التقادم او الاختراق
يعني ما طلعت الخليج لا تقارن يعني ما شاء
الله يعني الشخص لما يزورها يعني يزور
مطارات في المستقبل يعني بالنسبه لامريكا
فهي تعتمد على الولايه وعلى الميزانيه
وعلى الدخل اللي اللي الحكومه بتعديهم يا
فهو مش من الاولويات لهم يعني عندنا مطار
فرنسيس جددوها قبل الفتره المطار السنه
وزيد قبل الفتره بس لا يمكن توصل للمستوى
المطارده همم هذه خياليه شكرا جزيلا لك
على كل هذه هي التوضيحات كنت معنا من صفره
الدكتور احمد بدافع استاذ الهندسه وامن
الشبكات في جامعه الحسين
[موسيقى]
برر نائب المتحدث باسم حركه طالبان بلال
كريم قرار الاماره الاسلاميه في افغانستان
لاحكام الشرع وفي مقابله خاصه مع العربيه
قال ان النظام طالبان منح المراه حقوقه لم
تكن موجوده في السابق
تنا الاماراتي
كذلك قلل نائب المتحدث باسم حركه طالبان
بلال كريم من اهميه وجود تنظيم داعش في
افغانستان ووصفه بالظاهره التكفيريه غير
المرئيه واكد ان الاماره الاسلاميه قضت
على 98% من او كار لتنظيم مشيرا الى عدم
وجود حاضنه شعبيه لداعش في افغانستان
ان ظاهره داعش تكفيريه ليس لها وجود مادي
ومرئي وملموس في بلادنا فبعد مجيء الاماره
الاسلاميه تم القضاء على
98% من عناصر التنظيم وتم تدميره او تاره
ولكن من المؤسف ان بعض الدوائر تدعمه من
خلال الاعلام او تموله الاستغلاله ولكن في
الممارسه العمليه ما نراه في الواقع
الميداني لبلدنا هذه الظاهره لا تشكل
تحديا كبيرا وليست مصدرا قلق انجاد للامن
الداخلي في بلادنا ولا يمكنه ان يشكل
تهديدا من افغانستان الى دول اخرى
ما قدر عشره وقدرت تشيذي قرار النبي
مهما لكي نحتاج الى دول اخرى لمواجهته
داعش ليس تنظيما قويا وليسا مهما ليتمكن
من تجنيد الاشخاص عندنا وليس له مناطق
ثابته فحيث نجد نشاطا تخريبيا منفردا
تطارده قوات الدوله ومخابره الاماره
الاسلاميه ويتم تدمير او تاره
وتتابعون هذه المقابله الكامله لنائب
المتحدث باسم الطالبان بلال كريمي التي
اجرتها معه الزميلا ريمبو جمره يوم الخميس
الرابع عصرا بتوقيت جرينتش السابع مساءا
بتوقيت السعوديه على العربي
[موسيقى]
بعد قليل في اخبار الساعه الرئاسه
الاوكرانيه تصف المعارك في سوليدار بانها
الاسوا دمويه
وكذلك منذ بدايه الهجوم الروسي
[موسيقى]
مرحبا بكم من جديد
من الدماء والكثير من القسم والكثير من
الاشتباكات خصوصا في سوليدار تابعها ان
الخسائر العسكريه الروسيه الى والجيش
الاوكراني يخسر رجال ايضا خذوا ياك اوضح
انه بخلاف المعارك السابقه في المدن
الاوكرانيه في ماريو بول مثلا كان هناك
عدد قليل من المدنيين المتبقين في هذه
المنطقه
[موسيقى]
اما المتحدث وباسم الكريم للنادي متر
بتكون فقال ان القوات الروسيه تحرز تقدما
في العمليات العسكريه حول بلده سوليدار
لكنه اقر بتكبد القوات بلاده خسائر فادحه
هناكرانيه ان النجاح في العمليات العسكريه
سيتحقق عندما نحقق الاهداف التي حددها
القائد الاعلى للقوات المسلحه في سياق
العمليات العسكريه الخاصه بلا شك ان
النجاحات التكتيكيه مهمه جدا هذه النجاحات
تاتي بثمن باهض عبر البطولات الرائعه
لمقاتلينا وبالتالي هذا سبب اخر للفخر
بشبابنا الذين لا يدخرون لا صحتهم ولا
ارواحهم ليعطونا هذه النجاحات التكتيكيه
مراسلنا رائد الاغبر في دنياك والمزيد من
التفاصيل
على المناطق الشماليه والشرقيه من مدينه
سيلدار واضافت ان معارك ضاريه ما زالت وسط
المدينه وقل قائد قوات فاجنر الخاصه ان
جنوده سيطروا على وسط المدينه وطهروها من
ديون المقاتلين الاوكرانيين في ذات الوقت
الذي ما زالت فيه معارك ضاريه بين الجيش
الاوكراني والروسي في مناطق غرب المدينه
وتشير مصادره الى وصوله امدادات عسكريه
اوكرانيه الى نفس المحور لتعزيز دفاعاتكيه
بينما تتقدم القوات الروسيه من المحور
الشمالي نفسه للوصول الى مدينه سيفيرسك
التي يسيطر عليها الجيش الاوكراني شمالى
مقاطعه دانيسك بينما تطوق كامل القوات
الروسيه مدينه باخم وتنطلق من بلده اوبتنا
نحو العمقي في تلك المدينه نحو مدينه
ايفانكا
[موسيقى]
من اوكرانيا نذهب الى سوريا حيث ايران
توظف الاراضي السوريه وجهه لانظمها
الصاروخيه والهجمات الاسرائيليه الاخيره
على سوريا كان الهدف منها افشاله مشروع
ايراني جوي في سوريا فما هي اسرار هذا
المشروع الذي اثار اسرائيل على التصدي له
بكل حزن صحيفه نيوز ويك خابت بشكل دقيق في
تفاصيل الموضوع من خلال تقرير مفصل تقول
الصحيفه ان الامر يتعلق بمشروع مشترك بين
ايران وقوات النظام السوري بهدف في زرع
نظام ايراني مستقل للدفاع الجوي من داخل
سوريا وهو المشروع الذي صرفت من اجله
عشرات الملايين من الدولارات والهدف منه
التعامل مع الضربات الجويه الاسرائيليه
وتعود فكره في هذا المشروع الاتفاق
العسكري الموسع عنا توصل اليه كبار
ومسؤوليه الدفاع من البلدين في يوليو 2020
اتفاق تعاهد على اثره رئيس اركان الجيش
الايراني محمد باقري بان تقوي طهران
منظومه الدفاع الجوي السوريه في اطار
تعزيز العلاقات العسكريه بين البلدين
ويقوم المشروع الايراني على انشاء منصات
للصواريخ ووضع اجهزه رادار متطوره
باستخدام احدث الاسلحه الايرانيه ياتي في
مقدمتها صاروخ صياد هانتر بيفور الايراني
الذي يعمل بالوقود الصلب والذي تم الكشف
عنه في نوفمبر الماضي وتم اقرار قذفته
صاروخ الصياد بنظام صواريخ ارض جو بابار 3
7 3 التي يزيد مداها عن 188 ميلا كما ان
رادارها المضاد للطائرات يغطي دائره يزيد
قطرها عن 2008
المشروع الجوي الايراني في سوريا اشرف
عليه ابرز الخبراء الايرانيين والذين
كانوا هدفا للغارات الجويه الاسرائيليه
على امتداد السنوات الماضيه ياتي على
راسهم العقيده والجعفري القائد في قوه
الفضاء الجوي في الحرس الثوري الايراني
والذي تقول المصادر الصحفيه انه قائد
مشروع الدفاع الجوي الايراني في سوريا
وكانت ايران نسبت مقتل جعفر الى قصف على
جانب الطريق في دمشق نفذته اسرائيل
اسرائيل من جهتها اختارت التصدي لتهديد
الايراني القادم من سوريا مستهدفه مشروعها
الجوي من خلال غارات بدات اذا من سنه 2017
وكانت المطارات وهدفا اساسيا لهذه الغاره
اهمها مطار دمشق الذي تعرض لسبع غارات
اسرائيليه خلال العام الماضي وحده كذلك
الغارات الاسرائيليه استهدفت ايضا مطار
حلب والذي كانت تستخدمه ايران كقاعده
عسكريه وفق تقارير اسرائيليه ومن بين
المطارات التي استهدفت من قبل اسرائيل
ايضا مطار دير الزور العسكري الذي تستخدمه
كل من ايران وروسيا كنقطه مرور لشحنات
الاسلحه والجنود
معنى من باريس عبد الناصر العايد المحلل
العسكري السوري مرحبا بك معنا استاذ عبد
الناصر في اخبار الساعه من العربيه ماذا
نعرف ايضا عن طبيعه هذا المشروع الجوي
الايراني في سوريا
مساء الخير عزيزي الحقيقه يعني نعرف انه
حوالي 50% من الضربات الاسرائيليه ابتداء
من سنه 2017 او يعني من 2019 2017
وحتى الان نصف الضربات الجويه تقريبا
اسرائيل
استهدفت همم وحدات الدفاع الجوي السوري
سابقا همم وغالبا تتمركز همم فيها همم
يعني خبراء وعسكريين ايرانيين يحاولون
الاستفاده من شبكه الدفاع الجوي السوري
القديمه دائما كان يعني هناك تساؤل انه
لماذا تقصف اسرائيل شبكه الدفاع الجوي عن
النظام عن انها لا تشكل اي تهديد همم
نعم لماذا هذا المشروع ما كان الهدف
الحقيقي من وراء هذا المشروع الجوي
الايراني في سوريا في المطارات ومع
الانظمه الجويه سوريا
نعم الحقيقه هو من الوسيله الوحيده لدى
ايران لحمايه استثماراتها في سوريا اقصد
استثماراتها على الصعيد العسكري وعلى
الصعيد الصناعات الحربيه وعلى صعيد تواجد
ميليشياتها يعني كانت بدرجه كبيره تعمل ان
تقوم روسيا بهذا الدور لكن حدث تفاهم بين
روسيا وايران انه روسيا واسرائيل انه هي
يعني بتحمي النظام لكن ما بتحمي ما بتحمل
ايرانيين والميليشيات الايرانيه وعلى هذا
الاساس
ايران حاولت يعني همم
من باب الردع فقط استاذ عبد الناصر هي لم
تكن تنوي مهاجمه اسرائيل او ضرب اسرائيل
عزيزي هي القوات
الايرانيه الموجوده في سوريا هي يعني
لتمكين نفسها في سوريا وترخيص ترسيخ
وجودها في سوريا وهذا بالنهايه يعني
بالمدى البعيد هو يعني بالنسبه لاسرائيل
يشكل لها خطر لا اعتقد انه يعني كان من
مهمات هذه القوات الموجوده في سوريا الان
او منظومه الدفاع الجوي هي مهاجمه اسرائيل
لكن كما قلت لك هي محاوله
لحمايه هذا الوجود وقد فشلت الى درجه
كبيره يعني همم ايران لديها اوهام كبيره
او تشيع اوهام كبيره او القدراتها
الصاروخيه
حادثه وحيده همم اسرائيل في المقابل تقول
انها دمرت يعني هذا المشروع الايراني في
سوريا هل صحيح تمكنت من ذلك ام ما تزال
الميليشيات الايرانيه لديها خطط بديله او
استراتيجيات بديله هنا
لا يعني ليس لدي بالتاكيد معلومه دقيقه هل
دمروها ام لا لكن المعلومات الاستخباراتيه
التي تنشر بين 2 والاخرى تقول انهم يدمرون
باستمرار لكن معلوماتنا ايضا انه ايران
يعني كل شيء يدمر لها في سوريا تعيد بناءه
لديها تشبث غريب وعجيب بهذا البلد لا لا
يوجد يعني لم يحدث ان تم تدمير موقع الا
قامت باعاده بنائه مره جديده وارسال
واسلحه همم اليه همم المعلومات ايضا
المتوفره لدينا انه هي حاولت تنصب شبكه من
من همم من من من من من مضادات الطائرات
باور 373 وشبكه اخرى من منظومه خردات همم
هذه المنظومتين يعني حتى الان واضح جدا
انه فشلت في الدفاع عن نفسها على الاقل
همم ولكن هم يحاولون يعني وهم في طور
دائما عمليه محاوله تطويرتهم عادي شكرا
جزيلا لك عبد الناصر العايد
العسكري والسوري يكون معنا من باريس
[موسيقى]
بعد قليل في اخبار الساعه شرطه مكافحه
الارهاب البريطانيه تحقق في العطور على
مواد يورانيوم في مطاره هيثرو
[موسيقى]
مرحبا بكم من جديد قالت مصادر العربيه ان
منفذ الاعتداء على محطه قطارات الشمال في
باريس ليبيا الجنسيه وصل الى فرنسا قبل 30
سنوات وله ثوابق جنائيه والشرطه اصدرت
بحقه قرار بالترحيل الصيف الماضي وكان
منفذ الاعتداء اصاب سته اشخاص جراء عمليه
طعنه في لاجور بالعاصمه الفرنسيه باريس
حيث قامت الشرطه باطلاق النار عليه لينقل
الى المستشفى واقامت حواجز امنيه عندما
حطت القطار
[موسيقى]
طلب رئيس الوزراء البريطاني خلق توازن بين
حريه النقابات في الاضراب وفي الوقت ذاته
حق المواطنين في تلقي الرعايه الصحيه
وخلال الجلسه البرلمانيه الاولى له في عام
2023 دعسناك لنهج جريء وجذري لحليمه
اضرابات القطاع الصحي في بريطانيا
عندما يتعلق الامر بمساله الاجور فقد
قابلنا بالكامل توصيات المستقله لهيئه
مراجعه الاجور لا احد ينكر حريه النقابات
في الاضراب ولكن لابد ايضا من موازنه ذلك
مع حق الاشخاص في الحصول على الرعايه
الصحيه التي تنقذ حياه الكثير
[موسيقى]
الى المطارات مره اخرى تحقق سلطات
البريطانيه في ضبط رجال الشرطه شرطه
الحدود ضبطهم لطرد ملوث باليورانيوم
وقالت الشرطه انه تم تحديده كميه صغيره
للغايه من المواد
الملوثات بعد فحص موطنيا لطرد ضمن شحنه
معادن خرده وارد الى المملكه المتحده
وتحدث
انطلق من باكستان ووصل الى هيثرو عبر
ووفقا لصحيفه صن البريطانيه فان الطرده
كان في طريقه الى ايرانيين في بريطانيا
اشارت الشرطه ان المواد التي تم اكتشافها
لا تشكل تهديدا ولم تذكر التحقيقات حتى
اللحظه عن ارتباطها باي تهديد مباشره
في بريطانيا تحقق في تفاصيل طرد ملوث
باليورانيوم تم اكتشافه في مطاره برو بعد
عثور سلطات المطار على كميه صغيره من
اليورانيوم في التاسعه والعشرين من ديسمبر
الماضي خلال تفتيش الروتيني في الجمارك
ليتبين ان المواد المكتشفه من ضمن شحنه
قادمه من باكستان وعبر دوله ثالثه وتقول
تقارير صحفيه انها كانت متوجهه الى
ايرانيين في بريطانيا دون معرفه اهدافها
النهائيه
حول النشاط الايراني هنا في بريطانيا جاء
اخرها بعد الكشف عن شحنه من اليورانيوم في
المبنى الرابع هنا من خلفي في مطاره ورغم
قله كميه المواد المضبوطه الا ان مجرد
الكشف عنها يعني ان تهديد الايرانيه ماذا
لقائنا
وتثير الشحنه المضبوطه تساؤلات حول
الاسباب التي قد تدفع ايرانيين الى السعي
وراء الحصول على مواد كهذه في بريطانيا
وتكمل المخاوف في امكانيه استخدام كميات
قليله من اليورانيوم في صنع ما يعرف
بالقنبله القذره هدفها بالعاده استهدافه
الافراد بغبار المشع او تدمير منطقه
جغرافيه صغيره
رغم تاكيد الشرطه البريطانيه بعدم وجود
تهديد على حياه الناس حاليا الا ان
المعلومات هذه تاتي بعد اسابيع من كشف
السلطات البريطانيه عن تهديد الايرانيه
مباشره لافراد وصح فيهن ايرانيين معارضين
مقيمين في بريطانيا
تحتوي على اليورانيوم السام هنا في مطار
اهو تساؤلات حول اين وكيف ولماذا وصلت هذه
المواد الى هنا ولمن ومع المعلومات التي
تشير الى توجهها لايرانيين مقيمين في
بريطانيا يبقى الترقب قائما حول كيف
ستتعامل بريطانيا مع هذه التهديدات التي
باتت متكرره من لندن عروب عبد الحق
العربيه
[موسيقى]
الان سوى عن مذكرات الامير هاري هو الذي
وصل جذبه الاهتمام بعد ترحي كتابه في
الاسواق اصداروا الكتابه عاقبه تفاعل كبير
من طرف الشارع البريطاني من بين ابرز
التفاعلات التي لاقت اعجابا كبيرا داخل
بريطانيا الطريقه التي عرضت بها مكتبه بيت
بوكس المذكرات حيث وضعت كتاب الامير هاري
في الواجهه الزجاجيه الى جانب روايه
المؤلفه الى مكه التي تحمل عنوان
او كيف تقتلتك في اشاره لما يرمي اليه
الامير هاري بضع عائلته الملكه تغريده
المكتبه التي احتلت على صوره عرض الكتاب
بالواجه الزجاجيه حظيت بعشرات في
الاعجابات واعاده التغريد
الى جنب الانتقادات الحاده التي وجهها الى
افراد عائلته فان الاميره هاري ادلى
باعترافات مثيره للجدل من ابرزها زعمه قتل
25 شخصا من عناصر حركه طالبان اثناء خدمته
في افغانستان اعتراف الناقه انتقادا في
الداخل والخارج حيث قال الكولونيل
المتقاعد بالجيش ريتشارد كيم الذي اشتغل
في افغانستان ان الادعاء كان خطا في
التقدير اما ردود الفعل في افغانستان فقط
كانت ساخطه حيث قال المتحدث باسم وزاره
الخارجيه الاخرانيه عبد القهار بلخي ان
تصريحات هاري هي نموذج مصغر للصدمه التي
عانى منها الافغان كما غرد عضو طالبان
البارز انا استحقاني متوجهها بالكلام الى
الامير هاري قائلا بان من قتلتهم لم
يكونوا قطعه شطران بل كانوا بشرا كانت
لديهم عائلات تنتظر عودتهم هذا وعاد
الامير هاري للتعليق على الموضوع حيث
ادانا خلال حواره مع برنامج دلايت شو ما
وصفه بالتدليس الخطير فيما يتعلق الموضوع
نافيا مزاعم اتهامه بالتفاخر بعدد الاشخاص
الذين قتلهم
[موسيقى]
وفي ظل تراجع التاريخي للجنيه المصري امام
الدولار قال صندوق النقد الدولي الى مصر
تتجه نحو سياسه مرنه لسعر صرف العمله
الاجنبيه مشيرا الى انه يتوجه على الحكومه
ان تبرهن على مدى صمودها في هذه السياسه
وان المركزيه المصريه قد يواجه ضغوطا في
حال عكس هذا الاتجاهها واضافها صندوق
صندوق النقد الدولي ان اي تدخل للمركزيه
المصريه يجب ان يكون بهدف لتهدئه تقلبات
السوق فيما اشار الى المخاوف الناتجه عن
الانخفاض الحاد في الاصول الاجنبيه منذ
يونيو 2021 وكانت مصر قد توصلت في ديسمبر
الماضي الاتفاق مع صندوق النقدي الدولي
يتيح لها تمويلا بقيمه ثلاثه مليار دولار
لمده 48 شهرا
للمره الاولى تنخفض قيمه الجنيه المصري
لتكسر حاجز ال 29 امام الدولار الامريكي
البنك المركزي لم يعلق على هذه التطورات
التقديرات تشير بان الاحتياطي المصري يبلغ
34 مليار دولار اغلبها ودائع خارجيه من
قبل الدول الخليجيه ومن المتوقع وبحسب
خبراء ان تستمر موجات الغلاء خلال المرحله
المقبله
وكان صندوق النقد الدولي اكد اهميه
استخدام السياسه النقديه كاداه لكبحث تضخم
من قبل البنك المركزي المصري متوقعا ان
يتراجع معدل التضخم في مصر الى نحو سبعه
في المئه بحلول السنه الماليه 2024-25
واضاف الصندوق ان النظام سعر الصرف المدار
لم يخدم مصر وان الهدف هو تسعيل الجنيه
بشكل حر
اه ما ندري بوسي از بس السياسه النقديه هي
الاداه الاساسيه التي يجب استخدامها
لاحتواء التضخم كما اكدنا في تقريرنا
السياسه النقديه يجب ان تعتمد على
البيانات ومعادل الفائده يجب ان يستخدم
كادت اساسيه لذبح التضخم لضمان استقرار
الاسعار البنك المركزي المصري يحرز التقدم
بهذا الامر ومن مجرد اتخاذ اجراء نقل نظام
الاقراض المدعومي من البنك المركزي الى
الحكومه عندها سيتمكن البنك المركزي من
استخدام السياسه النقديه بشكل افضل لتوجيه
التضخم الى المستوى المستهدفه اسمحوا لي
ان اشير لان التضخم ما كان تحديا عالميا
هذا العامه ومصر لا تعتبر استثناء وبين ما
نتوقع ان يبقى التضخم مرتفعا نتوقع بلغه
معدل التضخم سبعه بالمئه بحلول السنه
الماليه 2020
افضل المنتدى الاقتصاديه العالميه تقديرا
جديدا حضر فيه من ابرز المخاطر العالميه
خلال العامين الحالي والقادم وكانت ازمتاه
تكلفه المعيشه وتغير المناخ على راس
القائمه التفاصيل في التقرير الثاني
سلطه المنتدى الاقتصادي والعالمي الضوء
على ابرز المخاطر العالميه لعام 20 23 على
راسها ازمه تكلفه المعيشه وتغير المناخ
وحذر المنتدى من الخلافات الجيو السياسيه
التي قد تؤدي الى زياده الضغوط الاقتصاديه
وتفاقم المخاطر
تقرير المخاطر العالميه يشمل اراء اكثر من
2100 خبيرا وصانع سياسه ويحث بدوره الدول
على التعاون والعمل معا لتجنب منافسه
الموارد ومن ابرز المخاطر خلال العامين
القادمين بحسب المنتدى ازمه تكلفه المعيشه
الكوارث الطبيعيه والاحداث البيئيه
الشديده
المواجهات جي اقتصاديه
الفشل في مواجهه تغير المناخي كلاش
التناغم الاجتماعي
اما على مدار سنوات القادمه
دخل الملياردير الامريكي الى الماسك
موسوعه جينيس للارقام القياسيه بعد ان حطم
الرقم القياسي العالميه الخاص باكبر خساره
للثروه الشخصيه في التاريخ خلال 2022.2020
[موسيقى]
اخبار الساعه انتهت اليكم تذكيرا بابرزها
يوم غير عادي في امريكا شلل يضرب حركه
الطيران بسبب خلل فني والسيناريو يتكرر في
كندا لكن بلا تعقيد
حكومه طالبان تقول للعربيه ان داعش ظاهره
التكفيريه غير مرئيه واقصاء المراه من
التعليم شانه الاماره
في مصر الجنيه في ادنى مستوى له امام
الدولار بعد الانتقال لنظام صرف اكثر
مرونه
بطريقه مبتكره مكتبه بريطانيه تروج لكتاب
الامير هاري عبر وضعه بجانب روايه كيف
تقتل عائلتك
شكرا لكم
[موسيقى]